PROFESSOR: All right,
so fluorescence.
You know, I know you
hear this from me a lot.
But this really is
my favorite topic.
The applications of
luminescence and fluorescence
in service to biology
are incredibly important.
So what I'm going to try
to do in these two lectures
is explain to you the
difference between fluorophores
that we can encode into proteins
through genetic engineering
and fluorophores
that we use that are
made by chemists in the lab
but then appended to molecules.
So today we'll talk about the
nuts and bolts of fluorescence.
And then on
Wednesday, we'll start
to see some of these tools
that you've seen images of.
We love to wow you with images
of fluorescent cells and cells
in action.
But I want to step back
and actually show you how
that all came about.
Where do these fluorescent
proteins come from?
What are we looking for?
How much protein
engineering was done
to make these such an amazingly
useful set of molecules,
macromolecules to really
allow us in real time
to study biology?
And there are many, many
other applications as well.
So we're going to talk about
luminescence and fluorescence
in general.
Luminescence is
the general term.
And fluorescence is a
little bit more specific.
There are different
types of luminescence.
And you'll get to see
some of those varieties
of luminescence.
I've put a decent amount of our
content today on the screen.
So we'll go up here
and take a look.
So luminescence in
general is the emission
of light not associated
with heat, not
like a burning flame which has
a lot of light accompanying it.
But rather the emission of
light in the absence of heat.
And there are different types of
luminescence the biologists use
intertwined into
biological experiments
to illuminate
life, to understand
details of cellular activity.
But also as reagents
in diagnostics
in all kinds of
imaging modalities.
And through these two--
three lectures, actually,
because Professor Martin
will give you one that has
even more imaging in it--
you'll sort of really get to
understand where these pretty
magical reagents come from.
So the two types of
luminescence that we
won't discuss in detail today,
first of all chemiluminescence.
This is a molecule
known as luminol
sitting in a little bile.
I think I like fluorescence so
much because the images are so
captivating.
Now, things like luminol, has
anyone heard of luminol before?
Does anyone-- yeah, do you
watch a lot of CSI or--
yeah.
So tell everybody what
people use luminol for.
AUDIENCE: To pick up on a blood
spatter or remnants of blood.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
when you see these TV
shows and there's this
beautifully clean motel room
and nothing looks like
it ever happened there.
But people thought there was
a murder took place there,
you'll notice they come in
with these spray bottles.
And spray all over the carpets,
and the drapes, and the chairs.
And then there's
this great moment
where they turn off the
light and luminol interacts
with the heme of blood at an
amazingly sensitive level,
such that when the
lights are turned out,
the room's just sort
of this battlefield
of bright luminescence
that indicates
that this was a crime scene.
So that's the most famous
luminol sort of example.
So that is what would be
called chemiluminescence,
the interaction of a chemical
with another chemical
to give luminescence.
Another pretty useful
type of luminescence
is bioluminescence.
I've done a lot of
scuba diving in my life.
And there's nothing more
exciting than a dive at night
where the whole ocean is
this sort of inky black.
And sometimes you'll
move your arms
through the black
water at night.
And you'll see all these,
like, little fireworks.
And many, many marine
organisms actually
undergo bioluminescence.
It's a biological reaction
that causes luminescence.
And this is a
cuttlefish shown here
in this image in
the corner where
they are brightly lit at night.
And actually, it's
just a whole party
there at night in the ocean
where all sorts of organisms
are signaling to other organisms
through bioluminescence
and reactions such as
luciferase reactions.
So in bioluminescence,
a molecule of ATP
is generally used and
combined with another molecule
through the action of
an enzyme that ends up
kicking out light energy.
So those are both important.
But what we're going to
talk about principally
is fluorescence.
This is a more specific term.
And you may wonder
why I'm putting
this in capital letters.
The first thing to
learn about fluorescence
is how to spell fluorescence.
So if you look at
the word fluorescence
and the first word first part
of the word looks like flower,
you know the stuff you
bake your pumpkin pie with,
you spelled it wrong.
It actually is
fluor, F-L-U-O-R-E-S.
What are you guys
whispering about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Did I get
something else wrong?
AUDIENCE: The E-S.
PROFESSOR: E-S, yeah, well,
forget about that part.
E-S. There's another C in there.
There we go, we
snuggled that in.
So the important part
is the first part.
So make it look like you know
what you're talking about
and spell fluorescence
correctly.
I cannot tell you
how many papers,
scientific papers I read where
they spelled fluorescence
wrong.
It's really hysterical.
It's one of those--
there's two or three
amazingly common typos
in people's slides.
One of them is spelling
fluorescence wrong
and the other one is
spelling complement wrong.
Complement as
opposed to compliment
where you're telling
someone they look good.
And complement
where you're trying
to sort of match up things.
Anyway, but fluorescence
is a key point.
So what is fluorescence?
It's the absorption of
light energy by a molecule.
Now it could be a
small, organic molecule.
It could be a small part
of a fluorescent protein
molecule that has a
particular structure.
But it will absorb light
energy at a certain wavelength.
So let's put this into
just a cuvette experiment.
These are the kinds
of little containers
that we use for certain
types of fluorescence.
We could use a plate
and a plate reader.
But this is quite common.
So you shine light
on this molecule.
Do you want to nab the doors,
the outer doors on both sides?
I don't know.
Everybody's pretty happy today.
Anyway, and the molecule goes.
And I'm going to
just draw something,
you know, with a bunch of
double bonds and things.
And the molecule absorbs light
and goes to an excited state.
So this is the ground
state before light.
After light you get the
molecule in an excited state.
So it has absorbed
that light energy.
So you've hit it with
a wavelength of light.
And I'm going to redefine
all these terms properly
in a moment.
Lambda excitation of a
particular wavelength.
Once that molecule
has absorbed light,
there's a very transient period
until the molecule lets out
energy in the form of light.
And returns back to
its ground state now.
So that the photo
physics of fluorescence
involves the excitation
of a molecule with light
of one energy.
That light energy is at
a particular wavelength
so it's called its
lambda of excitation.
That molecule very,
very transiently,
it's usually picoseconds
or nanoseconds
for organic molecules.
It may be a little bit longer
for other types of complexes
and may stretch to the
microsecond or millisecond.
But most of what we talk
about will be picosecond
to nanosecond lifetime.
And once it's excited, it
just drops its energy back out
and goes back to
the ground state.
And the most important thing
that you want to remember
is the wavelength, which
is given in nanometers.
And the wavelength for emission,
which is also in nanometers.
This wavelength
is higher energy.
Obviously you
don't create energy
when you shine
light on something.
You'd be breaking a few
fundamental rules if you did.
So the light that comes
back out is lower energy
because there's been
rearrangements in the excited
state of the molecule.
So you can't possibly kick
energy out at a higher energy.
And so this is a shorter
wavelength in nanometers.
And this is at a
longer wavelength.
So remember, higher energy
are shorter wavelength.
Lower energy are
longer wavelengths.
And that is a rule
for fluorescence.
When you excite a
molecule, you'll
take it to the excited state.
It'll sit and vibrate
there a little bit.
Then it will kick back energy
out at a longer wavelength.
And for the majority of the
fluorescence experiments
that we do in biology,
the wavelengths
that you see emission at
are in the visible range.
Whereas the wavelengths that you
might excite your molecule at
are often in the UV or a
bit longer, ideally, longer.
And these things are
going to come up.
This isn't the first time
that you're going to see them.
And it's not the last time
you're going to see them.
So let's take a look
at fluorescent dyes
in the electromagnetic spectrum
in the next couple of slides.
So what you see here, you see a
bunch of little eppendorf vials
with fluorescent
molecules that emit light
at all different wavelengths.
These would be down
at the ultraviolet end
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
These would be up in the very
red end, the lowest energy.
So these emission
wavelengths, these
would be emitting at the lowest
energy, longest wavelength.
These would be emitting at the
shortest wavelength, lowest
to highest energy.
Is everyone following me?
So just make sure
you remember that.
And just this principle
rule that you can't possibly
break with respect to
the wavelengths of light
for fluorescence experiments.
So what we're going to
see is the relationship
for the electromagnetic
spectrum.
There's a little bit
more detail in a minute.
And then look at
some fluorescent dyes
that are very, very
commonly used in biology.
And in fact, you
will have seen a lot
of cells stained with these
dyes even so far in pictures
that you've seen on the screen.
And then we'll talk about
the application of antibody
reagents and where does
that come in with respect
to fluorescences.
So let's take a
look at fluorescence
and the electromagnetic
spectrum.
So here it is, going
from wavelengths.
The ultraviolet wavelengths
would be shorter
than 400 nanometers.
So ultraviolet,
so beyond violet.
And the very red wavelengths
would be in the range
from 600 to 700.
And here you see
the relationship
between wavelength, and
then what the light emitted
would look like.
So if we're looking at here,
what we would expect to see
is if we've got a fluorophore
and it shows fluorescence,
we would be exciting
the fluorophore
in wavelengths in this region.
And we would see emission in
wavelengths in this region.
But a cardinal rule is that we
excite with a shorter, higher
energy wavelength
and observe emission
at a longer, lower
energy wavelength.
Now, there's very
important dyes.
Straight away the
most common dye
that you will see
immediately in biology
is a dye known as
ethidium bromide.
And here's its structure.
You can often
recognize fluorophores.
They have lots of rings
fused together with lots
of double bonds in them.
This is the structure
of a compound
known as ethidium bromide.
It's a dye that
intercalates into DNA.
And when the dye
changes its environment
from being in water to being
snuggled in between stacks
of base pairs in DNA, it changes
its fluorescent properties
and it becomes fluorescence.
So fluorescence isn't just the
intrinsic shape of the molecule
and what it looks like.
It's very, very often
related to what's around it.
Why is that the case?
It's because the excited
state may behave differently
in different environments.
Maybe stabilize for
a while, and that's
why you might see
fluorophores experience
a change in their
fluorescence as a function
of their environment.
Is that clear to everyone?
So the molecular environments,
if I'm a fluorophore
and I'm in water, I'm going
to feel pretty differently
in my excited state
if I'm a fluorophore
and I'm sitting packed
between DNA bases.
It's pretty dramatic
when you see it.
So when you mix ethidium
bromide with DNA,
and it could be in a cell or it
could be a lysate from a cell
where you're capturing the DNA
and trying to manipulate it
in recombinant biology.
That ethidium bromide will
intercalate into the DNA.
And it will light up
as a bright orange dye.
So here, say we've got a
gel that we've run DNA on.
We might have a
set of standards.
And in other places, we're
looking for the size of DNA.
Remember that
great experiment we
saw where we saw how quickly
small and large pieces of DNA
ran through an agarose gel?
So here is what
the DNA gel would
look like if you soaked
it ethidium bromide.
So here's the gel as
a ladder of bands.
But then let's say you wanted to
do some work on a piece of DNA
and maybe ligated you see DNA
pieces at different wavelengths
that have different
mobilities based on size.
We couldn't see
the DNA directly.
We couldn't pick it up.
We couldn't visualize it.
So we have to use
ways to visualize it.
One way is to radio label it.
Messy, we don't really
want to do a lot of that
if we can avoid it.
The other way is simply to
soak a dye into the gel.
And the dye, because of
the positive charge here,
the counter ion gets displaced.
And the positive
charge gets attracted
to the DNA and associates
with it quite tightly.
So that would be a way
that you would observe
DNA bound to dye in a gel.
And this fluoresces a
pretty long wavelength.
So this fluoresces
this bright orange
that's actually at about 605.
So you can see, this is
really in the visible range.
605 would be right around here.
And it has this bright kind
of orange fluorescence.
And the wavelength
that you would
use to irradiate
the dye on the DNA
would be a shorter
wavelength than 605.
You will often have
a prescription,
excite at this wavelength so
you observe at this wavelength.
And these are fixed
physical parameters
for fluorescent molecules.
Now, ethidium bromide is a
dye that can get into cells.
And we can look at
DNA within cells.
And here's a picture
of how it would look.
So here's the ethidium bromide.
And here's a pair of stacked
bases, this one and this one.
And there he is,
right in the middle.
See that ring coming
towards you is that.
And then here's this
thing that slides straight
between the bases and might
cause a little bit of a bulge.
And we would call this
a DNA intercalator.
It slides into the DNA.
And you can see over here,
the structure of DNA.
So you could picture
ethidium bromide
sliding between the bases.
Now, there's a big problem here.
Because you can't use
DNA ethidium bromide.
It's pretty toxic.
Why would it be toxic?
Well, no, it's not the bromide.
It's the fact, more,
think of what the dye does
when it gets to the DNA.
What would that do to
things like replication
and transcription?
It just kind of messes it up.
And so these are toxic dyes that
can only be used in fixed cells
to do observations of cells.
So we use it a lot.
We need to be careful
of it because if it
gets absorbed through our skin,
it could get into our cells.
And it could interfere
with replication
and other cellular processes.
Because it would accumulate
on our cellular DNA.
And in fact, the
interesting thing
that a lot of
molecules that actually
have these sort of
flat, pancake shapes
with lots of double
bonds are actually
pretty important in biology.
Because they end up being
chemotherapeutic agents.
So what I've shown
you here is what's
known as an
anthracycline structure.
I believe this is
adriamycin, I could be off.
But it's a natural product
that's isolated from bacteria.
And it has this
structure that also
makes it a DNA intercalator.
And it's used as a cancer
chemotherapeutic agent
because it interferes with cell
division and proliferation.
So we actually
exploit that property.
But only with cells that we
want to kill or stop dividing.
So you could picture,
well, I don't
want to use something
that's going
to interfere with cells if
I'm doing live cell imaging.
Because I'm going to have
trouble with the properties
of the cells.
So fluorophores are
great, but you've
got to worry about them because
they can get transferred
through the skin, through
cellular membranes
because they're
often quite greasy.
And they can get
in and interfere
with essential processes of DNA.
So because of this, there's been
quite a revolution in the work
done with DNA binding agents
that bind a little differently
and are way less toxic.
So I want to describe to you a
series of dyes that are known
as DAPI and HOECHST,
H-O-E-C-H-S-T. This was,
I believe, discovered in
a bio company in Germany.
And these are different
kinds of dyes that
fluoresce on binding to DNA.
So they are still useful
in that same context.
You can in fact substitute
ethidium bromide
with these dyes.
But they bind to DNA
pretty differently.
And I want you to take a
look at these pictures.
So here in green and blue-- and
apologies to the color blind--
you see a molecule of this
compound here bound to DNA.
So it's pretty clear it's
different from intercalation,
right?
You can see it's more sliding
around one part of the DNA.
And when those molecules
bind to DNA in water,
they don't fluorescence.
When they bind to DNA they
fluorescent an intense cyan
blue.
So that's at a shorter
wavelength from the ethidium
bromide.
So taking a look
at this structure,
does anyone want to explain
to me how the molecules might
bind to DNA?
We wouldn't call
it intercalation.
We know intercalation is
perpendicular to the axis
of the DNA.
So where, looking at this,
do you think these bind?
A while ago when I was talking
about the structure of DNA,
I like to think of DNA as having
two grooves, two places where
things combine to it.
And that's a minor groove.
And then this big trench is
what's called the major groove.
And certain molecules
bind in one groove.
And other molecules
bind in the other.
Where do you think it's binding?
Just by inspection.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Looks like
it's in the minor groove.
PROFESSOR: That's correct, it's
just snuggled just perfectly
in the minor groove.
If it was in the
major groove, it
would be swimming
around in that groove.
It's almost too big.
So what's really
cool about these dyes
is they slide in between
into the minor groove.
And they also make some
contacts with the phosphodiester
backbone.
But it's not that they're
dancing on the phosphodiester
backbone.
They're literally in the groove.
But there's some opportunity
for electrostatic interactions.
And so these compounds
would be known
to bind in the minor groove.
And in fact, they bind in
particular regions of DNA
where there's AT, not GC.
Those are the places
where there's just
the pair of hydrogen
bonds instead of the trio.
That's just their habit,
their personality.
So chemistry was
very important here.
You had a good dye,
but it was toxic.
But improved dyes
came along that could
be used in living systems
that are not toxic.
Because if you bind
in those grooves
and you're dissociating
easily, you're
not going to interfere
so much with replication.
Does that make sense?
So it's a weaker force.
It's not going to have a
big detrimental effect.
Now, I moved this slide up.
I realized he was in the
wrong place in the deck.
This is just an application
of the DNA minor groove binder
CEOCHST.
And in this case, we're
looking at three cells.
These two are not
actively dividing.
But take a look
at this cell, it's
actually clearly in the state
preparing for cell division.
And what you can see here
is that in the nucleus,
the DNA is pretty diffuse
before things really
start to condense and line up
for DNA replication and cell
division.
And what's intriguing to
me is that this rather
diffuse blue dye,
that's probably a bit
more loosely
associated with DNA,
becomes much clearer
and brighter when
the chromosomes are in the state
they're in for cell division.
So you can see them here.
And one question here.
So, if you're looking
at cells, you're
trying to observe cells,
where else in the cell
are you going to see DNA?
So we can see the
nuclear DNA, we
can see what stage of
the cell cycle it's in--
Yeah, Carmen.
AUDIENCE: The mitochondria.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in
the mitochondria.
So you could also spot
that within the cell
if you're at a
sufficient amplification.
So you know that there's not
DNA running around everywhere.
It's literally in very
specific places with the cell.
These dyes will bind also
to other nucleic acids.
But they don't bind so well.
Because those don't have
the really repetitive,
double stranded
nucleotide structures.
But there are other dyes that
bind much more specifically
to RNA.
But we won't discuss them.
So nucleic acids
seem to be something
that we can definitely
pinpoint with fluorescence.
We can see where it is.
We could follow cell division.
We could look to see the
progress of cell division.
For example, upon adding
things to a cell, can you see--
remember very, very
early on, we showed you
movies of cells dividing.
You could do that
with this kind of dye
because it's a non-toxic dye.
So, great, so far, so good.
So the key thing,
though, about biology
is we have so many other
entities within a cell
that we want to be able
to track and monitor.
And what we needed, what
is absolutely essential
are reagents to do that.
So I want to talk to you about
biological tools of monitoring.
And you know what these are?
These are antibodies,
monitoring proteins.
And in fact, you can
also coax antibodies
to recognize carbohydrates.
So I'm going to
just put these here.
But they're a little bit
harder to bind to antibodies.
But nevertheless,
those are useful.
So we're going to talk
now about antibodies,
which are agents of the
human adaptive immune system.
And how they have been exploited
intensively to study biology.
Now, what you will learn
from Professor Martin in two
or three lectures
time is much more
about the nuts and bolts
of the immune cells,
of the immune system.
And how it mounts a response
to disease and other features.
I'm going to focus completely
on the technological side
of antibodies and
how they are useful
reagents to study biology.
Because if you want to
recognize a protein in a cell,
you need a particular entity
that will bind to that protein
and show you where it is
through some kind of signal,
for example, fluorescence.
So what I want to do is give
you the minimal description
of antibodies so you
can understand this.
But later you're
going to revisit it
in a bit more complicated venue.
But for the time
being, I'm just going
to talk about B cells, which are
cells that produce antibodies.
And I'm going to
talk to you about how
they recognize their targets.
Because what we have in
the adaptive immune system
is an amazing system where you
can do combinatorial biology
and basically recognize
any target entity
you're interested in.
So let's take a look at
this, keeping in mind
that this is us
exploiting biology
to make reagents to do biology.
It's kind of a cool sort
of cyclical process.
So the cells of the
hematopoietic immune--
sorry the hematopoietic system,
those are the ones that are
important in blood cells,
form a lot of different--
wait a minute, I'm on triple--
triple tools here.
There are a bunch
of different cells
that are produced from the
pluripotent hematopoietic
cells.
They're either the white
cells or the red cell types.
But what we're going to focus
right in on are the B cells.
These are the cells of
the immune system that
produce soluble antibodies, OK.
And when you challenge
a B cell population
with a foreign entity,
the B cell population
will go into gear to
produce antibodies
that very specifically recognize
that foreign target, because
in the human adaptive
immune system, that
might be a wonderful tool to
get rid of that foreign entity.
So we're going to
focus exclusively
on the B cells and the
way that they mature
to produce soluble antibodies,
those are down at the bottom
here, based on what they've
been challenged with.
So what this little
schematic shows you is you
have a bunch of
different B cells.
And there's something
you want to recognize.
Let's just say it's a molecule--
an EGF molecule, a cytokine.
What you might do is
challenge this population
with the cytokine.
Only one B cell type will
bind to the cytokine.
And then that will
get amplified.
And then you will
end up with B cells
that produce a
lot of an antibody
to a cytokine such as EGF.
I'm truly dumbing this down.
I just want you to
get the gist of it
for the purpose of
this discussion.
Now B cells adopt a
very classical shape.
And I'm just going to show you
the quaternary structure of a B
cell--
of an antibody in
linear form here.
So it doesn't look very
exciting right now.
There are two light
chains, which I've just
shown in schematic form.
These are just
polypeptide chains.
And there are two heavy chains.
All right, so that's
their basic structure.
It's held together in
a stable quarternary
structure with this complex.
And there may be disulfides
across and throughout
the structure.
Now what's so special
about antibodies?
They're pretty big molecules.
The molecular weight
is pretty high.
But the key thing
about antibodies
is that the majority
of the structure
stays fairly constant.
So I'm just going to--
so this doesn't get modified
when B cells mature.
But another part of the
structure is variable.
And when B cells
mature, there's loads
of rearranging in that
variable section in order
that it adapt to bind to target.
So what you've seen here
is that the target--
see if this little
fellow works anymore.
No.
Ah.
What you see here
is the light chain
in green, heavy chain in blue.
And it's a double version of it.
We always draw antibodies
as this V shape.
And an antigen-- you've
heard this word before--
it's a foreign entity that's
foreign to the immune system.
The antigen binding
site is right here
at the tips of the antibody.
And I think the picture up
there is kind of clearer.
Let's put that forward again.
And you can see very
specifically the structure.
The C's designate
constant regions.
See C all the way through here.
And V's represent variable
regions, which I've shown you.
And at the tip of the V's are
the antigen binding sites.
So you're going to see
more about antibodies
in the immune system.
But what you want to
accept is that these
are biological macromolecules
that particularly evolved
to recognize target antigens.
And you can use them reliably
as biological reagents.
All right, so how do you
achieve the diversity?
There are hundreds of thousands
of different antibodies
in the human system.
If we had a gene for every
single different light
chain and every heavy
chain, you know, our DNA
would be completely
swamped by being
dedicated to the genetic
material for antibodies.
So instead there is
a particular system
which provides little
portions of the DNA structure
that are in little pieces
of variable components
that can get zipped together
through transcription
and slicing events to give you
a bunch of antibodies that have
different variable regions.
And this is what's
known as the BDJ system.
And you'll hear more about
that from Professor Martin.
So basically what you
want to think about
is it's a combinatorial system
to take little pieces of DNA
into a super molecular
structure to give you
antibody combining sites
that can recognize virtually
any target.
Anyone got any questions here?
I'm seeing a few worried faces.
Somebody ask me
a question if you
feel I could clarify
a component of this
or are you OK with this?
Anybody?
OK, I'll move forward.
So we talked about antibodies.
When you get a
population of B cells
that produce antibodies
to a particular target,
these may be what are
known as polyclonal--
a polyclonal-- sorry, I should
have written that up here--
a polyclonal antibody, as
might be suggested by the name,
is an antibody--
let's say it recognizes
a molecular entity.
So the antibodies--
I'm going to draw them as
little y shaped molecules--
may recognize different parts
of the antigen. So antibody A,
B, C recognize different
parts of the antigen.
Those would be polyclonal.
It would be a mixed bag
of antibody molecules
that shows specificity
for a target.
But people also tend
to use a great deal
of monoclonal
antibodies, because they
are a lot more specific.
So if you had a selection
of polyclonal antibodies,
a monoclonal antibody would
be a single population
that recognizes a single
antigen or epitope
in your antigenic molecule.
And the way those are made is
through the engineering method
where you fuse spleen
cells with myeloma cells.
And then you get a hybrid--
what are known as hybridomas
that produce very specifically
just monoclonal antibodies.
So that's a bit of background
there about the antibodies.
You'll see it on the rerun
when Professor Martin talks.
But I just wanted to give you
a bit of exposure to this.
So let's now look at how
antibodies can be useful.
So let's say you want to
visualize in a cell-- let's
move straight to a real
targeted application.
We want to make an antibody
that might recognize actin
and a different antibody
that might recognize tubulin
to take a look at cells through
the use of antibody structures.
The way you generate antibodies
is through laboratory animals.
And very commonly we use
either mice or rabbits
for antibody production.
The rabbit is used when you need
a lot more antibody material.
The mouse will satisfy
for some experiments.
So the way you make
antibodies is by injecting.
So this would be the
foreign agent or antigen
that you want to
make an antibody to,
which would normally bind
at the variable region
of this immunoglobulin molecule.
You inject the mouse
with that antigen. Excuse
me-- that's a rabbit.
You know, I haven't been
in biology very long.
But I can tell that's
a rabbit, right?
Anyway, so you inject the
rabbit with a human protein.
If you-- what
would happen if you
injected the rabbit with rabbit
actin or with rabbit tubulin?
What would you-- would you
expect to see a response?
No, right?
Yeah.
Because the
organisms are adapted
not to recognize
their own proteins
unless there's some disorder
like an autoimmune disease.
So you would inject the
rabbit with a human epitope,
so for example human
actin, generate antibodies
with a specificity
for actin, and then
you would label those antibodies
with a fluorescent marker,
so you could track it or
follow it through chemistry.
Alternatively, you might want
to make a different antibody
for tubulin.
And then you would differentiate
the antibody against tubulin
from the antibody against
actin by labeling it
with a different
color fluorophore.
So you've really got two
types of macromolecule
that can be interacted
with a fixed cell
and recognize those
two macromolecules
within the protein.
So what's important
here is that you
don't use the protein from--
if you want to
study human cells,
you use antibodies produced
in rabbit or mouse.
If you want to
study rabbit cells,
you could produce it
in different organisms.
You're not going to produce the
antibodies in the same host.
Nowadays-- yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you know that
you have the correct antibody,
like if that is the right one?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so you would prepare the--
you would do them.
There's a lot of
screening takes place.
So you inject the
mouse or rabbit.
And then you collect the serum.
And you look for
whether the serum
gets enriched and
enriched in antibodies
that recognize the target.
So you'll see an increase in
what's known as the titer.
And then once you get
a high titer, you'll--
unfortunately, you can
just collect the serum
or depending if you
want to make monoclonal,
you'd have to sacrifice the
animal to get the spleen cells.
But then you collect
the antibodies
through an affinity
method that's
directed just at antibodies.
Then you've got your population.
And you can throw a
fluorophore dye at it
and chemically label it.
So it's a good point there.
There's a lot of
work being done now
with antibodies from
different organisms, in fact,
you'll see them from camels.
And they're also
ones from shark.
And the reason why they're
kind of interesting
is that they sort of have mini
antibodies that are much more
useful for technology.
So let's see what
we can do here.
We can do fluorescence
experiments.
In order to do this
with an antibody.
And this is going to highlight
a shortcoming of antibodies.
You may take a
cell that you want
to observe different
proteins in that cell,
you have to fix the cell
to make it permeable.
Why do I need to make
the cell permeable
in order to use these
antibody reagents?
Do you think the antibodies
are just going to cross--
DAPI gets into a cell easily.
But what about antibodies?
Can they cross the
plasma membrane
to get into the cell
to label a target?
What do you think?
Who says yes?
Who says no?
Good.
Thank goodness.
OK.
You guys don't say much.
But I know you know
the answer here.
They just can't
float into cells.
They're too large
to get into cells.
So you have to fix the
cells on a glass side
and permeabilize them,
for example, with methanol
so that the antibodies
can gain access
to all parts of the cell.
So here is a bright
field view of cells.
That's a little
bit more specific.
That's OK too.
But this is what I
really want to show you.
This is what you could achieve
with DAPI and an antibody
to the actin and an
antibody to tubulin.
And you can look at
the various colors
of the fluorescence emission.
And you see here what you've
got is an anti-actin antibody
with a red dye.
And you can see that at the
perimeters of the cells.
You've got an anti-tubulin
antibody with a green dye.
And you can see the
filamentous structure there.
And then you've got DAPI
staining bright blue
where the nuclei are.
So you have three
unique labels that
fluoresce at
different wavelengths
and you can directly
pinpoint things.
So fluorescence is extremely
valuable for looking
a biological systems, because
we don't have a lot that
fluoresces in the body.
So a cell in general, if
you irradiate it with light,
you won't see any major
fluorescence at all.
So these reagents that
you use to study biology,
if they fluoresce, you've got
unique signals where you can
look at really complicated
cells that may have thousands
and thousands of proteins,
sugars, nucleic acids,
and very specifically see
things by fluorescence
because the fluorescence is
a unique signal in biology
relative to the intrinsic
fluorescence of proteins
or rather macromolecules.
We have tryptophan and tyrosine,
a couple of amino acids.
They fluoresce, but it's so dim.
It's nothing like this.
You wouldn't see those
kinds of signals at all.
It's really what we call
extrinsic fluorophores,
fluorophores from outside that
shine very, very brightly.
Many of these fluorophores
shine so brightly they
can be used to look at
in single molecules--
professor Martin
described to you
single molecule DNA sequencing.
That actually exploits
very bright fluorophores
that is so bright that you
can see just a few of them
in one place very, very clearly.
OK, how am I doing?
I just want to
actually leave you
with something that's
another technology.
So you could almost picture--
with all of what
we've seen so far,
you could almost target any
cell with an antibody that's
specifically raised to a
particular protein that's
within the cell.
So we can see--
in the next class we'll discuss
what the limitations of that
are.
But we've already
talked about the fact
that we have to use antibodies
with fixed, not living anymore,
cells.
So they are really dyes that
can only be used in that way.
The other place you
can use fluorophores
is for labeling DNA and
from looking at DNA.
And a particularly
important technology
is known as a DNA microarray
has anybody heard of these?
Yeah.
So DNA microarrays absolutely
exploits the complementarity
of DNA sequences.
So if you want to probe for
a particular sequence of DNA,
you would make the
complementary strand
and label it with a fluorophore.
And new could, out of thousands
of DNA stretches, literally
light up the stretch
of DNA that's
complementary to your target.
And so DNA microarrays--
what you see here
are just the size
of just a microscope slide.
On this slide through
arranged technologies,
you can literally spot 40,000
distinct sequences of DNA
in grids to recognize.
So these DNA
microarrays can be used
for profiling genetic material
or for profiling not just DNA,
but RNA, and we'll see
how at the beginning
of the next class, in order to
probe for particular stretches
of DNA that might
be disease related
and have single
nucleotide polymorphisms.
So in order to actually just
give you a little bit of a warm
up to that, I want you to go--
I'm going to put a link
to this in the web site.
And it actually just shows
you a virtual running of a DNA
microarray experiments
and how you
can use it to profile
disease states
and cells versus healthy cells.
And then at the beginning
of the next class,
I'll describe how you
get information out
of DNA microarrays.
But at the end of
the day, you're
always using the
fluorophores as the probes
for where certain
things are, OK.
And the thing to remember here.
Fluorescence is a
magnificent tool.
We can use fluorophores
on their own.
as attached to antibodies.
And the DNA
microarray experiments
show you how you
can use fluorophores
attached to DNA sequences, OK.
And I'll see you
in the next class.